[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend es ist ein Tag der
in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen wird
der morgige Samstag auch wenn es einige
aus Politik Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
noch immer nicht so ganz wahrhaben
wollen die letzten drei noch laufenden
Atommeiler gehen morgen definitiv vom
Netz konkret sind das dieser zwei in
Bayern das Kernkraftwerk Emsland in
Niedersachsen und Neckarwestheim zwei in
Baden-Württemberg betrieben wird
Letzteres von EnBW mit dessen Chef werde
ich gleich über Ausstieg Umstieg und
Kohle
im doppelten Sinne sprechen zuvor der
Blick von Petra Otto und Max schwarz auf
ein Unternehmen das vorbereitet ist
hier ist sie bereits am Start die
Energiewende der süddeutsche
Energiekonzern MBW will ganz vorne mit
dabei sein baut um legt im Kraftwerk
Stuttgart Münster die Kohlekessel still
ersetzt sie durch Gasturbinen für ein
paar Jahre betrieben mit Erdgas dann mit
grünem Wasserstoff
Versorgungssicherheit für die Stadt sie
sehen an zum Tag und genau dann fehlt
uns Strom im Netz und genau diesen Strom
wird dieses wenn diese Gaskraftwerke die
wir hier in Baden-Württemberg neu
installieren
immer mehr Heizung die mit Strom laufen
mehr E-Autos Elektrizität soll die
Energie der Zukunft sein gerade jetzt
die Stromquelle Atomkraft endgültig
aufzugeben das halten nicht alle für
klug kurzfristig sehe ich jetzt weniger
Probleme die Atomkraftwerke abzustellen
aber mittelfristig stellt sich eben die
Herausforderung dass wir noch nicht
sicher wissen ob wir die Erneuerbaren
Kapazitäten und die gaskapazitäten zur
Verfügung haben werden die wir brauchen
um den Strom in 2030 dann auch noch
bereit zu stellen
2030 so dass ehrgeizige politische Ziel
sollen 80% bei der Stromgewinnung
erneuerbare Energien sein bloß bei der
Windenergie da gibt es ein eklatantes
Nord-Süd-Gefälle Niedersachsen
produziert fast sieben Mal so viel
Windenergie wie Baden-Württemberg da
hapert es nicht zuletzt einen schnellen
Genehmigung im Norden dagegen müssen sie
sogar öfter abschalten wegen zu viel
Stroms
um künftig Strom von Nord nach Süd zu
transportieren braucht es Stromtrassen
die es bis heute noch nicht gibt das ist
beschleunigt worden von den gesetzlichen
Vorgaben von den Planungen der
Unternehmen von den Genehmigungen der
Bundesnetzagentur wenn das jetzt alles
ineinander greift da bin ich
zuversichtlich dass wir das schaffen
können nur wann und zu welchem Preis das
ist noch offen der Anteil der
Erneuerbaren bei der Stromerzeugung
wächst stetig insgesamt aber Sonne und
Wind sind eben nicht konstant so waren
es am 21 Mai letzten Jahres sogar mehr
als 80% erneuerbare Energien am 16
Dezember aber eben nur knapp 16 diese
Schwankungen die sind das Problem und in
Karlsruhe suchen Sie nach Lösungen wie
sich das Netz stabil halten lässt
wir brauchen eigentlich speichern die
sagen mal im Idealfall saisonal
speichern könnten und da wäre zum
Beispiel eine Lösung elektrolyseure man
produziert aus dem Strom der dann eben
überschüssig produziert wird
beispielsweise Wasserstoff Wasserstoff
den Sie zukünftig wieder in Strom
umwandeln wollen zum Beispiel hier im
Kraftwerk in Stuttgart eine
Herkulesaufgabe diese Energiewende und
kein bisschen einfacher durch den
Atomausstieg morgen
kompliziert und komplex das ist auch die
Aufgabe des Chefs von EnBW Deutschlands
drittgrößtem Energiekonzern und damit
ein schönen guten Abend Andrea
guten Abend Frau Hayali aus
Neckarwestheim ich freue mich sehr mit
ihnen zu sprechen vielen Dank für ihre
Zeit ist denn der Ausstieg aus der
Kernkraft zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht
vielleicht doch ein Fehler
worüber reden wir wir haben einen vom
Bundestag beschlossenes Gesetz zum
Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie und das
gibt uns ganz klare Vorgaben nämlich
morgen mit der Stromerzeugung durch
Kernenergie die Stromerzeugung dich
gerne Energie zu beenden und darauf
haben wir uns vorbereitet und planen das
eben auch morgen zu tun und damit mega
Western vom Netz zu nehmen ich war schon
etwas überrascht über die Intensität der
öffentlichen Diskussionen in den
vergangenen Tagen und ich würde mich
würde mir wünschen wenn wir genau diese
Diskussion umlenken würden in eine
Diskussion über den Umbau unseres
energie-systems den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und damit wirklich
unser Energie System der Zukunft zu
gestalten aber es gibt ja eben auch
einige offene Fragen und Sorgen auf die
kommen jetzt im Laufe des Gesprächs auch
noch zu sprechen aber vielleicht noch
mal nachgefragt dieser Ausstieg ist ja
auch um den Preis das klimaschädliche
Kohlekraftwerke als Reserve einspringen
werden wo erneuerbare noch nicht genügen
zugebaut sind selbst bei ihnen stammen
ja noch rund 45 Prozent der Energie aus
Kohleverstromung
ich denke das Thema müssen wir wirklich
ganz offen und ehrlich ansprechen dass
wir in den nächsten Jahren verstärkt
Kohlekraftwerke und Gaskraftwerke unter
anderem auch zur Reserve zum Einsatz
bringen müssen und damit natürlich auch
die CO2-Emissionen in Kauf nehmen müssen
aber das macht den Punkt doch umso
deutlicher warum wir jetzt gerade den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren intensivieren
müssen denn immer dann wenn die
Erneuerbaren da sind gehen eben auch die
CO2-Emission runter also bei ihnen ist
ja der Kohleausstieg geplant für 2028
klappt aber auch wirklich nur wenn die
Bundesregierung mehr Tempo gibt als
jetzt und dass sie das jetzt auch alles
ich will mal sagen schön reden sagen sie
das jetzt auch weil Ihr Unternehmen ja
auch fast zur Hälfte dem Land
Baden-Württemberg gehört und der
Ministerpräsident ein grüner ist
zunächst einmal haben wir als als
Deutschlands einziges integriertes
Energieversorgungsunternehmen natürlich
ein ganzheitlichen Blick auf das Thema
Energiewirtschaft und mit den Bereichen
Erzeugung aber auch den Netzen und
natürlich den Konsumenten den
Verbrauchern ein einen Blick darauf wie
dieses System umzugestalten ist und aus
unserer Blickrichtung heraus ist das
Jahr 2028 eine Kombination von den
möglichen mit dem Machbaren das haben
wir uns eben entsprechend so durch durch
simuliert und sind dann zu dem
Entschluss gekommen dass 2028 ein
mögliches Jahr für den Kohleausstieg ist
aber auch und das ist mir ganz wichtig
zu benutzen wenn die entsprechenden
Rahmenbedingungen gesetzt werden und
wenn wir vor allen Dingen in die
Umsetzung gehen der der geplante der
geplanten Maßnahmen noch mal den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien das ist Wind
offshore ganz klar Erzeugungen im Norden
Wind und schon Photovoltaik wo es
oftmals dann auch zu Konflikten kommt
hinsichtlich der Flächennutzung aber und
genauso wichtig wir müssen auch die
Stromnetze für die Zukunft ausbauen und
umbauen damit der Strom eben dort wo er
produziert wird auch zu den Konsumenten
gebracht wird genau das passiert ja noch
nicht nochmal aber an der Stelle
nachgefragt warum sie das auch alles
befürworten man würde nämlich ja
vermuten dass sie als Betreiber der mit
Kernkraft auch viel Geld erwirtschaftet
hat er das sagen was zum Beispiel der
Chef von Isar 2 richtig findet und der
bayerische Ministerpräsident Söder seit
Tagen überall sagt weitermachen auch
wegen der Versorgungssicherheit warum
hat denn der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Unrecht
vielleicht darf ich den Blick noch mal
ganz kurz zurück berichten in den
vergangenen August wo standen wir in den
vergangenen August fahren wir haben uns
über das Thema Versorgungssicherheit
netzabschaltung gasmangel Lage
unterhalten und wir müssen doch zur
Kenntnis nehmen dass im Zusammenspiel
zwischen der Politik und der
Energiewirtschaft wir gut durch den
vergangenen Winter gekommen sind wir
haben eine echte Energiekrise in
Deutschland gemeinsam vermieten und
damit natürlich auch gezeigt dass wir
ein System haben wo noch Reserven da
sind das Netz entsprechend zu
stabilisieren und für eine sichere
Stromversorgung zu sorgen hier in
Deutschland Versorgungssicherheit ist
uns als EnBW enorm wichtig und aus dem
Grund geht es jetzt bereits darum dass
wir den Blick auf den nächsten Winter
eben entsprechend legen und uns darauf
vorbereiten
neben der Versorgungssicherheit spielt
natürlich auch noch die finanzielle
Seite eine Rolle viele Deutsche glauben
dass die Energiepreise im Zuge der
Energiewende weiter steigen werden sie
auch
wir sehen derzeit immer noch starke
Schwankungen was die Energiepreise
angeht das wäre schlichtweg nicht seriös
wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche Aussagen
treffen würde über die zukünftigen
Energiepreise aber eines kann ich Ihnen
ziemlich sicher sagen dass beobachten
wir immer dann wenn wir Erneuerbaren
wenn wir Strom wenn wir Energie aus der
neuen Energien haben dann gehen die
Großhandelspreise nach unten und das ist
tendenziell genau die richtige Richtung
auch für die Konsumenten in unserem Land
das ist mit der Grundlast wie wollen Sie
das regeln
da ist die EnBW ja bereits in
Vorleistung gegangen wir haben drei an
drei unserer kohlestandorte in der
neckarschiene das heißt den Heilbronn in
Stuttgart Münster und Altbach Deizisau
wir haben an diesen drei Standorten
Gaskraftwerke geplant und wir werden
diese grafgaskraftwerke mit einer
enormen Anstrengung und bin eine
Investition von 1,6 Milliarden wir
werden dort 1,5 Gigawatt an elektrischer
Leistung durch Gasturbinen installieren
das in einer Rekordgeschwindigkeit so
dass wir Ende 26 diese Gasturbinen dort
zum Einsatz haben und das bedeutet für
die Menschen in der Region potenziell 50
% weniger CO2 Emission durch die
Energieversorgung sagt der Chef von EnBW
Andreas schell vielen herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Zeit und alles Gute
einen schönen Abend danke
die Ziele der Bundesregierung bis 2030
80 Prozent des Stroms sollen aus
Erneuerbaren kommen 6 Millionen
Wärmepumpen sollen bis dahin installiert
werden und 15 Millionen Elektroautos
soll es bis dahin auf Deutschlands
Straßen geben nur gibt es viele der
nötigen Rohstoffe und Produkte die es
braucht um all das Realität werden zu
lassen nicht bei uns sondern in China
sollten also die Beziehungen zu China
langsam aber sicher Abkühlen wie die
bremsstäbe in den Atommeilern dann wären
die Klimaziele in Gefahr all das weiß
die Außenministerin natürlich und so war
sie bei ihrem Antrittsbesuch in China
wohl auch freundlich im Ton aber hat in
der Sache wie Andreas kühners beobachtet
hat
es geht damit los dass China Deutschland
entgegenkommt und zwar genau 140
Kilometer weit noch ein bisschen
zerstruppelt ist Jing Gong der Staatsrat
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten und
Außenminister der Volksrepublik China
hat gestern wieder lange mit seinem
russischen Freund lavroff
zusammengesessen jetzt kommt das
gegenprogramms Gast war Mitglied bei
Amnesty International war Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Freundeskreis Taiwan
und gilt in Pekings Presse als Anti
China Ministerin das Gong Anna-Lena Borg
in der Industriestadt
chen beim Besuch eines deutschen
chinesischen Zulieferers für
Elektroautos begleitet war nicht
unbedingt zu erwarten aber China hat
eine Botschaft
wir sollten strategische
Missverständnisse oder
Fehleinschätzungen vermeiden wir sind
Partner keine Gegner
sehen als Partner und als System Rivalen
das weiß Gong natürlich und wie die
grüne Ministerin am liebsten reist auch
im Sonderzug nach Peking kommen die
Unterschiede auf den Tisch die Bedrohung
Taiwans die Menschenrechte Russlands
Angriff auf die Ukraine ein Mann sagt
Werbung könne diesen Krieg morgen
beenden und ein Land China habe ein
Fluss auf diesen Mann namens Putin
muss offen sagen dass ich mich frage
warum die chinesische Positionierung
bisher nicht die Aufforderung an den
Aggressor Russlands beinhaltet den Krieg
zu stoppen wir sehen unsere Funktionen
der Ukraine Frage darin Versöhnung zu
fördern und Friedensverhandlungen
voranzubringen wir werden nicht weiter
Öl ins Feuer gießen
dann wird die Pressekonferenz zu einem
Schlagabtausch so offen so konfrontativ
wie in Peking selten erlebt Werbung
spricht die Unterdrückung der Uiguren an
für Gong sind die Berichte darüber Lügen
Werburg nennt militärische Drohungen
gegen Taiwan nicht akzeptabel Gong sagt
China werde keinen Zoll Territorium
preisgeben und dann das Thema das Peking
am wenigsten hören will
dass wir es mit Sorge sehen dass
Freiräume für zivilgesellschaftliches
Engagement in China immer weiter
schrumpfen und Menschenrechte
beschnitten werden
unser Austausch sollte auf Respekt und
Gleichberechtigung beruhen was China am
wenigsten braucht sind Lehrmeister aus
dem Westen
es endet damit dass Deutschland China
entgegenkommt dass sich bärbock eine
Stunde und einen Stadtführer nimmt und
Respekt zeigt vor einer großen Kultur es
ist nicht gut gelaufen mit Chinas
Regierung heute vielleicht hilft ja eine
andere macht
mehr über den China-Besuch von
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock finden
Sie in unserem Online-Angebot und da ZDF
heute sich unabhängiger machen vom Reich
der Mitte dazu waren ja sowohl Kanzler
als auch Außenministerin in letzter Zeit
viel im globalen Süden unterwegs auf der
Suche nach neuen Partnerschaften
Probleme diese Länder haben bereits
viele Deals mit China so auch Brasilien
Gundula und dessen Präsident ist gerade
auch unterwegs und zu Gast in China
und Präsident zeigte sich mit Chinas
Präsident einig die Zusammenarbeit
Brasiliens und Chinas wird weiter
vertieft nicht nur in den Bereichen
Energie und Infrastruktur Chinas
Präsident hi sagte es gehe strategisch
um eine neue Ära der Beziehungen zu
Brasilien 15 Abkommen wurden
abgeschlossen Lula war mit einer großen
Wirtschaftsdelegation nach China gereist
in Bezug auf die Ukraine sind sich hier
und Lula einig dass Dialog und
Verhandlungen der einzig mögliche Weg
sein um die Krise zu lösen
in der Ukraine wird weiterhin
insbesondere um bachmut im Osten
gekämpft nach Einschätzung britischer
Geheimdienste hält die ukrainische
Verteidigung starkem russischem
Artilleriebeschuss stand wegen
erheblicher Nachschub Probleme hätten
sich ukrainische Soldaten aber aus
einigen Positionen zurückgezogen die
russische Seite behauptet rund 80% der
zerstörten Stadt erobert zu haben
überraschend hat Russland in Mitten
massiver Spannungen mit dem Westen mit
einem großen Flottenmanöver begonnen und
dabei seine gesamte Pazifikflotte in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt über 80
Kriegsschiffe und ungute sowie Einheiten
der luft-
nach dem Abzug der Bundeswehr aus Mali
im kommenden Jahr soll die
Zusammenarbeit mit dem westafrikanischen
Land weitergehen das erklärte
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius nach
einem Treffen mit seinem Amtskollegen
Kamera das Ende des Bundeswehreinsatzes
ist auch Folge eines Streits mit den
Militärmachthabern über
Einsatzbedingungen im Kampf gegen
islamistische Extremisten setzt Mali
aber weiterhin auf Militärberater und
Ausrüstung aus Deutschland
heute standen in Frankreich 9 Weise im
Fokus der Nation gemeint sind damit die
neuen Mitglieder des Verfassungsrates
die darüber zu entscheiden hatten ob die
Rentenreform des französischen
Präsidenten verfassungskonform ist oder
nicht die sieht vor das
Renteneintrittsalter schrittweise von 62
auf 64 Jahre anzuheben seit Wochen gibt
es dagegen massive Proteste also gegen
diese Reform auch weil macron das
umstrittene Gesetz ohne Abstimmung und
damit am Parlament vorbei durchgesetzt
hatte und durchgesetzt hat auch er sich
heute Anna wassberg
kein Wort keine Tendenz Drang hier vor
18 Uhr durch die Mauern des streng
bewachten Verfassungsrates nach außen
die neuen Hüter der Verfassung haben
heute eine Entscheidung getroffen mit
der Präsident macron sein Ziel erreicht
hat das Gesetz ist im Kern
verfassungsgrundform das heißt die
Erhöhung des Renteneintrittsalters von
62 auf 64 Jahre ist gebilligt abgelehnt
werden lediglich einzelne Artikel wie
die Regelung die Unternehmen dazu
verpflichtet Senioren zu beschäftigen
eine Absage erteilt der Rat auch der
Forderung der linken Opposition nach
einer Volksabstimmung der Protest folgt
prompt ich bin 66 mich trifft das alles
nicht mehr aber ich kämpfe für die
jungen Leute und für die die knochenjobs
machen müssen
zurückzieht es ist eine Reform die die
Regierung allein gemacht hat die
Gewerkschaften wurden dabei nicht
angehört
um die Rentenreform sondern um die Art
wie sie durch geboxt wurde ohne
Abstimmung im Parlament und so wird auch
entscheidend sein wie die Regierung
jetzt kommuniziert
Premierministerin born äußert sich wie
er Twitter das demokratische Verfahren
dieses Gesetzes ist nun beendet heute
gibt es weder Sieger noch besiegte
die Gewerkschaften sehen das anders sie
wollen hart bleiben auch wenn macron nun
seit langem erstmals wieder mit ihnen
sprechen will die Gewerkschaften sagen
ganz klar dass wenn der Präsident der
Republik dieses Gesetz verabschiedet
keine Gewerkschaft ihn oder ein
Regierungsmitglied treffen wird um über
etwas anderes als die Rücknahme dieser
Rentenreform zu sprechen
die extreme Rechte in des versucht den
Streit nicht auf der Straße sondern im
Parlament für sich zu nutzen betont ihre
Treue zu den Institutionen
wir sind Republikaner man kann diese
Instanz nicht anfechten aber ich sage
den Franzosen es gibt eine Lösung Marine
Le Pen 2027 zur Präsidentin wählen
der Verfassungsrat hat sein Urteil über
die Rentenreform gefällt aber das Land
kommt nicht zur Ruhe im Gegenteil
die politische Krise ist nicht vorbei
wir haben es mit einer Regierung zu tun
die im Grunde keine Verbündeten mehr im
Parlament hat also tendiert für Sie die
Möglichkeit Gesetze zu verabschieden
gegen Null die politische Krise hat
gerade erst begonnen
und so endet das monatelange Ringen um
die Rentenreform vorerst mit einem
geschwächten Präsidenten und einem
aufgebrachten Volk
und eines ist schon auch spannend die
Mitglieder des Rates so ist es Usus sind
unter anderem vom Präsidenten ernannt
worden und Kippen äußerst selten Gesetze
vollständig in Frankreich tja welche
finanziellen Schmerzen können eigentlich
Sanktionen auslösen darüber wird ja
immer wieder ziemlich viel spekuliert
insbesondere wenn es um Russland geht
und da gibt es jetzt Gundula aufs Öl
bezogen wirklich valide Zahlen
Russlands Ölexporte sind trotz der
Sanktionen der westlichen Länder auf den
höchsten Stand seit drei Jahren
gestiegen das schätzt die Internationale
Energieagentur Stefanie berrett wer sind
denn die Abnehmer des russischen Öls ja
man mag es ja eigentlich kaum glauben
vor einem Jahr noch lieferte Russland
knapp die Hälfte seiner gesamten
Ölexporte in die EU Deutschland deckte
vor dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine ein Drittel seines Öl Bedarfs
aus Russland mit dem europäischen Öl
embargo hat sich das nun radikal
geändert seither strömen die russischen
Ölexporte verstärkte Richtung China
Indien und in die Türkei Indien
steigerte seine öl-einfuhren aus
Russland im vergangenen Jahr im
Rekordtempo nämlich um das 22-fache
Tendenz steigend doch obwohl Russland
seine Einnahmen aus dem Ölgeschäft im
März um eine Milliarde auf 12,7
Milliarden Dollar kräftig steigern
konnte im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind sie
um 43 Prozent eingebrochen hier wirkt
also das europäische embargo offenbar
denn seitdem spülen die Ölexporte
insgesamt deutlich weniger Geld in
russische Kassen weil Rosneft und
look-oil ihren neuen Großabnehmern
erhebliche Rabatte gewähren müssen um
ihr Öl loszuwerden deshalb klingen die
aktuellen Zahlen auch besser als sie
tatsächlich sind beim DAX da stimmen die
Zahlen heute zeitweilig erklimmt er
sogar ein neues Jahr hoch und auf
Wochensicht gewinnt das deutsche
börsenmachometer sogar 1,3% dazu vielen
dank Stefan Frankfurt
zum Sport im Freitagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga hat Schalke 04 am
Abend Hertha BSC zu Gast es ist das
Kellerduell der beiden Tabelle letzten
viele Tore fallen da ganz kurz vor knapp
steht es da jetzt vier zu zwei für
Schalke
und noch eine Meldung vom Tennis auch
Jan Lennard strff ist beim ATP Masters
von Monte Carlo ausgeschieden der
32-Jährige verlor im Viertelfinale gegen
den Russen André ruble 1 zu 6 und 6 zu 7
zuvor war Alexander Zverev an Daniel
medjew gescheitert
unter dem Motto beste Aussichten ist in
Mannheim die Bundesgartenschau eröffnet
worden auf einem ehemaligen
Kasernengelände sind 1,3 Millionen
Blumenzwiebeln gesetzt und
Zukunftsbäume gepflanzt worden das Ziel
die nachhaltigste BUGA aller Zeiten
Schirmherr Bundespräsident Steinmeier
würdigte den Vorbildcharakter durch
kluges Anlegen von Grün verbesserten
sich Lebensqualität und Stadtklima
nachhaltig
der Jupiter ist der größte Planet
unseres Sonnensystems und hat über 90
bisher identifizierte Monde und die
diese jetzt hier sehen das sind die vier
größten die sogenannten
gallischen
Galileo Galilei ja Monde entdeckt wurden
die Achtung 1610 durch Galileo Galilei
mit einem selbstgebauten Fernrohr fragen
Sie mich bitte nicht wie genau das
eigentlich funktioniert hat spannender
ist auch eh das was heute gelangen die
europäische Sonde juice ist zu ihrer
Mission gestartet und wenn sie dann
irgendwann mal in ca 8 Jahren angekommen
ist soll sie herausfinden ob es dort
grundsätzlich Leben geben könnte
Christina Kajaks über eine Reise die 1,6
Milliarden Euro kosten soll
es ist eine Zitterpartie bis zum letzten
Augenblick
die Spannung im Kontrollraum der Isar in
Darmstadt ist mit Händen zu greifen um
14:14 Uhr steigt die Ariane 5 in den
Himmel über Kuru
auf die Sekunde pünktlich denn das
Zeitfenster ist extrem klein die
Erleichterung riesengroß
die Rakete hat sich von der Erde weg
bewegt und jetzt sind wir auf dem Weg
Richtung Jupiter und das ist schon mal
wichtig
doch weiter werfen sie bange Blicke auf
die Anzeigetafeln hat die Sonde die
gewaltige Wucht des Staats auch
unbeschadet überstanden noch wissen sie
es nicht dass ersehnte Lebenszeichen von
juice kommt später als erwartet dann
aber ist es da
lang sehr sehr lang hat es noch mal
spannend gemacht wir sehen auch jetzt
noch dass das Signal noch relativ
schwach ist wir wissen noch nicht genau
warum aber wir haben Signal
jetzt verläuft alles wie geplant die 85
Quadratmeter großen Sonnensegel
entfalten sich und sichern damit die
Stromversorgung der Kontrollraum
übernimmt das Kommando von hier aus wird
jetzt die lange Reise zum größten
Planeten unseres Sonnensystems
acht Jahre wird juice unterwegs sein bis
sie den Jupiter erreicht den unbekannten
Gasriesen den mehr als 90 Monde
umkreisen unter ihnen Europa kalisto jo
und ganimet
er ist der größte der eisigen Monde des
Jupiter und steht im Fokus dieser
Mission die Forscher vermuten unter
seiner gefrorenen Oberfläche flüssiges
Wasser
und flüssiges Wasser ist eben einen der
Bestandteile die wir brauchen um Leben
zu bilden deswegen sind diese eismonde
so interessant um sie als mögliche
Habitate für die Entstehung von Leben zu
untersuchen und ganimed ist insbesondere
darüber hinaus noch interessant weil er
als einziger Mond ein Magnetfeld hat und
wir nicht genau verstehen wie wird es
gebildet
wie die Oberfläche von ganimed genau
aussieht und wie tief der Ozean darunter
ist sollen der Höhenmesser Gala und die
Spezialkamera Janos erforschen sie
wurden in Deutschland mit entwickelt und
sollen den fernen Eismond wieder und
wieder umkreisen mit messen genau die
Entfernung die die Sonde zum zu der
Oberfläche hat und damit kriege ich
natürlich ein Höhenprofil also wenn auf
einmal ein Hügel in der Oberfläche ist
dann ist die Laufzeit unterschiedlich
und damit kann ich das genaue
Höhenprofil erforschen
es wird noch viele Jahre dauern bis die
Daten und Bilder vom äußersten Rand
unseres Sonnensystems bei uns ankommen
aber die Hoffnung ist groß dass Sie uns
helfen können die Geschichte des
Universums besser zu verstehen
und ich übe noch ein bisschen das Wort
Galileische Monde das war es jedenfalls
von uns unser journalblick in diese Welt
und darüber hinaus jetzt kommt hier die
heute-show und gegen 0 Uhr melde ich
mich noch mal mit unserem heute-journal
Update darin ein Gespräch zum
Atomausstieg mit einem industrievorstand
der das kritisch sieht bis später und
wir sehen uns dann hier wieder gemeinsam
Morgen wenn Sie wollen machen Sie es gut
wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend zum
Wetter heute gab es richtig deutliche
wetterunterschiede in der Westhälfte des
Landes startete Tag richtig sonnig da
kamen zwar im Tagesverlauf hier und da
Quellwolken dazu auch mal einen Schauer
aber mit dieser Unterstützung der Sonne
reichten wir hier frühlingshafte 16 Grad
in der Osthälfte dagegen da lagen die
Wolken am Alpenrand kam die Werte nicht
über vier Grad hinaus und aus diesen
Wolken viel auch einiges an Regen teils
Dauerregen in den ostdeutschen
Mittelgebirgen dieser Regen gehört zu
einer Warmfront eines 5b Tiefs so nennen
wir das Tiefs aufgrund seiner Zugbahn um
die östlichen Alpen herum und heute
Nacht und morgen schiebt es sich weiter
aus Osten in Richtung Deutschland heute
Nacht regnet es also zwischen
Schleswig-Holstein und Ostbayern
oberhalb von 900 Metern fällt auch
Schnee Nordosten allerdings lässt der
Regen langsam nach aus Osten frisch der
Wind auf im Westen und Südwesten ist es
bis zum Morgen oft klar so dass die
Nacht hier wieder kalt wird mit bis -2
Grad im Osten bleibt es milder mit fünf
bis acht Grad morgen erreichen wir dann
meist 10 bis 16 Grad an der Mosel aber
unter den Regenwolken und im Südosten
Deutschlands bleibt es mit vier bis neun
grad nochmal deutlich kühler dazu regnet
es weiter zwischen der Nordsee und dem
Alpenrand obwohl der Regen von Norden
her schnellen Nachlast auch aus
Tschechien her im Tagesverlauf lässt
dann der Dauerregen in den ostdeutschen
Mittelgebirgen nach am meisten ist es
wohl im Stau des Thüringer Waldes und
des alpenrandes mit um 15 Litern pro
Quadratmeter morgen auch in den nächsten
Tagen geht es dann mit viel Regen weiter
aus Norden setzt sich mit einem hoch
aber trockeneres Wetter durch das war's
von uns tschüss